こんちはっすぞ熱々です by 皆さんだけど今お昼時でございますはいこのように
お腹が減っております腹が減っております今出たのもデリバリー何のデリカピザ食べ
たいぴーツアーいいですねえっつ
次9月に作ってた所ピザ組作っての車刻む組も好きなのに組に食べれないかなって座組
食べれな辛さの嫌な思い出コメントそういったぞですよ
女島下それはいどピザを食べたいんですけども今日はちょっと4つのせっかくいいに来
てるんであのちょっと特殊のたたみ方で今回もせっかく運んでくださる方も多分普通に
ピザ
受け取っても楽しくないからす冥福にならない
ちょっとパゴ伴奏してそうですね方で楽しんでエンターテインメントをしてぴ線人も
慣れで楽しくてピザ
私に来てくれたらいいなというみんなハッピーがんばっ踏み込んないですよね人バーリ
って皆さんご存知でしょうか
ま僕がやったことあるんではからなんだの事はなんだかねもっとワークフロー
まあ服があるんですけどその中で2人入って鳥は鳴りまし内で見るんですけどもう一人
がなんかその人もての役割ですねひとつの服に2人
はいそれか
今日は前の人だけどは毎日が後ろ乗っていそうですねこれ本当にチームワークないと
いけない
今回それでちょっとピザを受け取ってあっ
あった一応無関係練習勝負言ってるんだけどかなんかないですか
うわーっ
ああっ洗い場じゃないんですよただアッここにあるじゃないですか
ここにあるばーんわー
ブーブー言っニャー
rar
ああああもうこれやるしかないけど一さんや橋からですもうこれはもう避けられない
これはもう避けられない
なんで刷毛で申し訳ないけど
ブーブーどうすればいいなぁこれでいこうこれ全然んんんんんっああっ
俺の腕じゃないですからねえと言うけどね今これ僕のじゃなくて牛
非常にいる4つのでございます凄い所ココでこれを使ってちょっとピザ屋さんのピザを
受け取ってあるべくそのちょっとね
ピザを受けてる時は僕じゃないすよっちが前になるんでなるべくねちょっとあるいない
モデル東て皆さんの一音少しでも指森練馬は少しよりピザの人この二人羽織で楽しい
肝吸いさせればいいなと思って
います前は以降デリバリー頼みたいんですけど a 2はい
ん
はいからさん
はいよろしくお願いまあはいというわけでピザの注文完了したのであとは待つだけで
ございます
を生んだ
ん
アッパ西武センチとりあえずです
はいありがとうございます
re あのー打ったが右に外れないけど
集め地別に最初くださいパッソたいです
優れた
ええええええ
とっています
サービス突破えっと
2良いそれじゃっ一年間
pou dou dou
応募方法谷氏は言えなかった
car
レッサー鈴の入ったでかいぞ
あっそうありがとうございますありがとうございますありがとうございました
薄着
これあれチェーン人じゃないですかよかったね良かったです
あのんなもんなんか笑ったけど良かった